they're a real threat and they're
scattered over thousands of hectares in
Northern Donetsk
landmines along with other remnants of
War are preventing many people from
returning home Ukraine says Russian
troops placed a large number of Mines
all over the area
as Al Jazeera accompanied a demining
crew a missile landed near a house it
didn't explode and the crew headed
towards it
Alexia demining technician says remnants
of missiles must be examined carefully
they're dangerous especially if the
missile doesn't detonate this area is
now clean it's safe the crew gets back
to its task demining the area around a
major power line so Engineers can
restore power supplies
come on
yes
this is the start of the war we've
removed more than 40 000 mines and
unexploded projectiles across the netsk
alone We Believe deliberated areas now
housed three times that number each year
of War means 15 years demining work
of course the war is far from over many
villages are still being bombarded many
more are without electricity heating gas
or water during The crucial winter
months despite all of this Victoria
refuses to leave her home she's made it
her job to feed dozens of pets abandoned
by their owners in her neighborhood
many pets were left behind their
innocent creatures we all hope that this
horror will come to an end one day and
we can restore peace we suffered under
occupation for more than seven months we
are free now but the situation is still
dire elsewhere in the province Villages
have been totally destroyed there's not
much for residents to come home to even
if they wanted to Nadine barber Al
Jazeera